so if my dad sits me down and we're in
the kitchen it says look at Albert
and he says what about it he says just
look at him look how happy he is
he says he says that's the happiest
person I know in my life so look at him
he says be very careful reading these
books I said why he says because the
moment you have too much knowledge
you're gonna lose the innocence of being
happy because you know nothing yeah
exactly so you that was Albert that was
Albert so the point you have to choose
in life unless if you just want to live
a innocent happy life that you're just
chilling kicking and not giving a [ __ ]
about they couldn't even know you asking
what the Dow Jones is he's gonna think
it's a lady next story hell down I said
hello you know but the but the point is
if you choose to really pick up a book
and read you can enter a world us right
damn I better kind of learn to make some
adjustments but if you just want to live
a life like Albert dude more power to
you every family needs an Albert